Lisa Marie Presley has died aged 54 the
singer and the only child of rock and
roll legend Elvis had been taken to
hospital after suffering possible
Cardiac Arrest our U.S correspondent
Martha Kellner has the latest from Los
Angeles
Lisa Marie Presley was a very well-known
figure in Hollywood not just because she
was the daughter and the only child of
rock and roll legend Elvis she also had
marriages to Michael Jackson and
Nicholas Cage she too was the owner of
her father's Graceland property in
Memphis Tennessee which she's made into
one of America's leading tourist
attractions the first hint that we got
that something had gone terribly wrong
with her health was when Emergency
Services were called to her home in
Calabasas a suburb of Los Angeles after
she she suffered a suspected cardiac
arrest her mother Priscilla the pair
were very close then wrote on Instagram
asking people for their prayers for her
daughter but it was just a few hours
later that Priscilla Presley released a
statement I'll read that now she said
it's with a heavy heart that I must
share the devastating news that my
beautiful daughter Lisa Marie has left
us she was the most passionate strong
and loving woman I have ever known we
ask for privacy as we try to deal with
this profound loss the Presley family is
no stranger to grief or premature death
Lisa Marie was just nine years old when
her father Elvis died of a heart attack
at Graceland in 9 1977 and just a couple
of years ago Lisa Marie's son Benjamin
died by Suicide and she's recently wrote
an essay talking about the profound
effect grief like that has on an
individual the Presley family once again
in mourning for Lisa Marie Presley this
time who's died at the age of 54.